مدد الدول وانعدام بينها الولايات المتحده
باقتحام وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
ثمار بن غفير ومجموعه من المستوطنين باحات
المسجد الاقصى تحت حمايه الشرطه بالتزامن
مع اول جلسه عقده حكومه نتنياهو الجديده
اعتبرت الفصائل الفلسطينيه لاقتحام
استفزازا غير مقبولا ينذر بعواقب وخيمه
واعتبرته سلطه الفلسطينيه تحديا خطيرا
لمشاعر الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاث مسارات ما هي
حيثيات وملابسات واقتحام وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي للمسجد الاقصى بعد
عمليه تمويهم وتضليل حول موعد الاقتحام
وما الذي تعنيه هذه الخطوه في ضوء اتخاذها
طاب عن رسميا هذه المره
اي رساله نقرا في توصيف الفصائل
الفلسطينيه عمليه الاقتحام بالخطوه
للاستفزازيه المنذره بحرب دينيه في
المنطقه وكيف يمكن
لسلطه الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
وما دلالات اهمال الحكومه الاسرائيليه
المطالب الامريكيه بعدم القيام بخطوه
استفزازيه بشان المقدسات وماذا عن ردود
الافعال العربيه والاسلاميه والدوليه
[موسيقى]
على حين غره وبعد تمويهم بشان التوقيت نفذ
وزير الامن الاسرائيلي ملوح به وقام
باقتحام باحات المسجد الاقصى
ليطفي بذلك طاب عن رسميا على العمليه التي
اثارت غضبا
وانتقادات عربيه واخرى امريكيه وغربيه كل
ذلك
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده ستعبا بمن
يعارض او ينتقد سياستها وكذلك عما قد تذهب
اليه مستقبلا من ممارسات تحذيرات متصاعده
من تسببها في انفجار المحتمل
وفي ردود الفعل قالت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
ان اقتحام وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
بنغفير باحات المسجد الاقصى تحدي
للفلسطينيين وان استمرار الاستفزازات
سيؤدي لتفجر الاوضاع كما قال رئيس الوزراء
الفلسطيني محمد اشتيه ان اقتحام وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي لتمرد
للمسجد الاقصى يشكل تحديا خطيرا لمشاعر
الشعب الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
بن غفير للمسجد الاقصى المبارك صباح اليوم
يشكل تحدي خطير
لمشاعر جميع ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني وعليه
ندعو ابناء شعبنا الذين احبطوا مؤامره
البوابات الى التصدي لمثل هذه الاقتحامات
التي تستهدف في جعل المسجد الاقصى مع بدن
يهوديه وهذا انتهاء لكل الاعراف والقيم
والاتفاقيات والقوانين الدوليه وتعهدات
اسرائيل للرئيس الامريكي
كما دنت الفصائل الفلسطينيه اقتحمى وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي المسجد الاقصى
واعتبر التروس استفزازا غير مقبول ينظر
بعواقب وخيمه
الجبانه من بن جبير تمثل تصعيدا خطيرا
واستفزازا لمشاعر شعبا الفلسطيني والامه
العربيه والاسلاميه ينذر بحرب دينيه في
المنطقه
ثانيا الاحتلال الصهيوني يتحمل كامل
المسؤوليه انت داعيات اصراره في العدوان
على شعبنا الفلسطيني
والمقدسات الاسلاميه والمسيحيه وخاصه تسلل
المجرم المتطرف بن كبير المسجد الاقصى
ثالثا ندعوا ابناء شعبنا في القدس والضفه
والداخل المحتل الى شد الرحال للمسجد
الاقصى المبارك وتكثيف الرباط فيه
لافشان المخططات التلموديه الصهيونيه
الفلسطينيه الشيخ محمد حسين شدد على ان
عمليه الاقتحام تحمل طابا عن رسميا وانه
تم بموافقه الحكومه الاسرائيليه ورئيسها
هو يقتحم بصفه رسميه حيث انه وزيرا للامن
القومي الاسرائيلي وبالتالي هذا يعطي صوره
واضحه بان هناك توجه لدى هذه الحكومه
اليمنيه المتطرفه هذه الحكومه التي تتشكل
من مستوطنين ويدعمون الاستيطان ويدعمون
الاستيلاء على الارض الفلسطينيه ويدعمون
كذلك محاولات السيطره على المسجد الاقصى
المبارك باتمام المخططات الاسرائيليه
رانيا الى فرض واقع جديد في المسجد الاقصى
وتغيير الوضع القائم
والوصول الى التقسيم الزماني والمكانين
للمسجد الاقصى
وفي المواقف الدوليه نقله موقع اكسيوس عن
السفير الامريكي في اسرائيل توم نايس ان
اداره بعيدا اوضحت للحكومه الاسرائيليه
انها تعارض اي خطوات من شانها الاضرار
بالوضع الراهن في الاماكن المقدسه واكد ان
واشنطن تريد الحفاظ على الوضع الراهن وان
الاجراءات التي تمنع ذلك غير مقبوله
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من غزه الدكتور
صالح النعامي الخبير في شؤون الاسرائيليه
وسيمض الينا لاحقا من نيويورك السفير
مارتن امريكا السابق لعمليه السلام في
الشرق الاوسط نبدا معك يا دكتور صالح
النعامي في الرسائل التي ارادت حكومه
اسرائيل حكومه نتنياهو بالتحديد ان ترسلها
من خلال عمليه الاقتحام اقتحام وزير الامن
القومي
للمسجد الاقصى
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده ااا يعني
تبعت برساله واضحه
وصارخه بانها توقف منذ الان
استراتيجيه اداره الصراع وتنتقل الى
استراتيجيه حسم الصراع حسم الصراع في
المسجد الاقصى يبدا باطفاء صفه رسميه على
مساله على مساله تدنيس المسجد الاقصى ثم
بعد ذلك كما يقول بين كبير بشكل واضح
وصريح بانه يتوجب السماح لليهود باداء
الصلوات المديه في داخل المسجد وبعد ذلك
التقاسم الزماني والمكاني
انتهاء الى السيطره الكامل على المسجد
الاقصى وهذا ايضا بالمناسبه حسب الصراحه
ينطبق على مجالات اخرى حسن الصراع على
الارض عبر ضم مناطق جيما لتشكل اكثر من
60% من الضفه الغربيه لاسرائيل
حسن الديموغرافي كما تدعو حركه همم
يهوديته التي يتدعمها او المناعه اليهوديه
التي زعامها
والتي تدعو بشكل واضح وصريح الى تاجير
الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه والقدس
وفلسطين 48 ايضا والحس في مواجهه المقاومه
عن طريق تشريعات تسمح بفرض احكام الاعدام
على المقاومين وتغيير اوامر اطلاق النار
بحيث يتم قتل اكبر عدد ممكن من فلسطين لكن
فيما يتعلق بالمسجد الاقصى الامر بالغ
الخطوره لانه حركت اسماعيل يهوديته او
حركه المانعه لهديه التي يقودها ثمار
وحركه الصهيونيه الدينيه التي اراسها وزير
الماليه مودريتش هاتان الحركتان التي
اللتان تحزان على ثمانيه حقائب وزاريه في
هذه الحكومه تنتميان الى التيار الدين
الخلاص التيار الديني الذي يقول بانه
سيتحقق الخلاص اليهودي عندما ينزل المخلص
المنتظر وهذه يتوقف على اندلاع حرب ياجوج
وماجوج وهذه الحرب لن تندلع الا بعد اقامه
الهيكل على انقاذ المسجد الاقصى
ذلك الامر الحديث يدور عن استراتيجيه
شامله تفرض يفرضها اليمين الديني المتطرف
على يمين نتنياهو يفردها هذه الجمله وهذه
الجمله هذه الجمله مفتاحيه ان كان اليمين
المتطرف هو الذي يفرض على نتنياهو هذه
الاجنده سنسال عن هذا الموضوع لكن انضم
الينا سفير مارتن اندر اكسيد مارتن اندك
من وجهه نظرك كيف قرات هذا الاقتحام لوزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي للمسجد الاقصى
على الرغم من تحذيرات سابقه او مطالبات
امريكيه سابقات بعدم تغيير الواقع في
المقدسات
ان هذا مؤشر واضح
حول اي اي اين تتواجه هذه الحكومه الجديده
في اسرائيل
في الامر لم يحصل فقط بسرعه بالتوجه نحو
الحرم الشريف
وال ايضا اعلن بان سيكون ذلك الشهريا وفي
هذه الحاله سيكون لدينا حوادث شهريه مثل
هذا النوع
واعتقد انك شيء اخر مهم في هذا الموضوع
ينبغي ندركه وهو طريقه التعامل مع هذا
الموضوع بمحاوله تغيير الوضع الخائن
الحالي بطريقه بحيث يصنعون القلب بانهم لا
يغيرونه
همم يسمح لليهود
بانوا يدخلوا همم
الحرام الشريف وهم يفعلون ذلك منذ سنوات
ولكن لا يسمح لهم بالصالات
خاصه اريل شعرهم كمان تذكر في عام 2000
وهما قبل ذلك ادى ذلك الى الانتفاضه لكن
في سنوات الماضيه ابعدوا
عن ذلك الان لدينا وثيقه جائع او دخل هلا
صغير وضع القائم هذا مؤشر
الرغبه في تغيير الوضع القائم الحالي او
تهديد بتغييره ولكن بحيث ذاته هذا لا يغير
وضع القائم ذلك شديد
الولايات المتحده ينبغي ان تضغط على
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بان لا تقوم بزياده
مثل هذه الخطوات الاستفزازيه وعلينا نفهم
انه سيكرونا ذلك مثل هذا الامر همم
رغم عدم تغيير الوضع القائم يعني
يكررون ذلك مقابل المطالبات امريكيه بعدم
تغيير الوضع القائم لكن عمليا بالتكرار
الوضع القائم يتغير بشكل او او باخر هذه
نقطه صعود اليك همم للحديث عنها سيد مارتن
عندك لكن كيف مرت عمليه اقتحام باحات
الاقصى بمطبخ القرار الرسمي الاسرائيلي
مراسل اكس نقل عن مسؤول في مكتب رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي ان نتنياهو طلب في
خلال محادثات بينهما ليله امس التنسيق
مسبقا قبل صعوده الى الحرم القدسي مع جميع
المسؤولين الامنيين نتنياه كان قد اكد في
اج لحكومه ان حكومته الجديده موحده حول
سياسه اسرائيل الامنيه وذلك على خلاف
الحكومه السابقه التي كانت موحده فقط من
اجل منع هو ومعسكر اليمين من العوده الى
سده الحكم بحسب تعبيره هنا نعود الى همم
الدكتور همم
صالح النعامي همم طيب عندما نسمع بوجود
هذا التنسيق بين نتنياهو بنغفير مع هذه
الضبابيه في همم توقيت وكيفيه حصول عمليه
الاقتحام
هل هذا الامر مفروض فردا على نتنياهو اما
انه يعني هذا يلبي رغباته التي لم يكن
يستطيع ان يقوم بها سابقا بوجود اليمين
المتطرف الان هذا الامر كان يتمناه سابقا
في الحقيقه علينا ان نتذكر قبل الاجابه عن
هذا السؤال طبيعه طبيعه الظروف التي ادت
الى تشكيل هذه الحكومه هذه الحكومه شكلت
همم وهذا التحالف ما بين الكود الذي يراس
بين يمين نتنياهو قوه اليمين الديني جاءت
لانه بنيامين نتنه في الان في ازمه كبيره
هو يحاكم في قضايا فساد وهناك حاجه الى
تمرير ما يسمى القانون الفرنسي الذي
يعفينا المحاكمه لا يوجد احد في داخل
الكنيسه مستعد لمن هذا القانون والتصويت
لصالح هذا القانون الا هو اليمين الديني
وبالتالي هؤلاء يتحكمون الان في بني ميمنه
ولا يوجد الذي يملي سياسات الان هو يتمار
بين كبير
لانهم يدركون بانه بدون مشاركتهم في
الحكومه فرص ان يذهب من يمينه للسجن الى
امل بعيد يعني فرس كبيره لكن الاستاذ حسن
علينا فقط للعوده الى المقابله ضعيفه الس
عندك لما يتعلق بانه لم يحدث تغيير الوضع
القائم علينا نتذكر انه في العام 2015 تم
التواصل اتفاق ما بين ملك الاردن ورئيسه
الوزراء الاسرائيلي الحالي الذي كان ايضا
رئيس وزراء في ذلك الوقت من يمينه ياهو
بواسطه بوزير الخارجيه الامريكي فيحيني
جون كيري وتم الاتفاق في هذا الاتفاق اتم
الاتفاق بين الثلاثه على الا يتم السماح
باداء الصلوات التلموديه على الاقل يتم
السماح همم باعضاء وقاده همم الحركات
الحركات الهيكل بتدميز المسجد الاقصى لكن
علينا همم كلنا شهدنا في العام الماضي
وشهادنا همم
غلاه اليمين الذين يريدون الصلوات المديه
ويدون الرقصات الدنيا في داخل المسجد
الاقصى اثمار بن كبير وهو وزير كما كان
معروف اعلن بشكل واضح وصريح بانه لن يسمح
بما اسمها تمييز العنصر ضد اليهود طبعا
قصده تلاميذ العنصر ضد اليهود انه انه اذا
كما انه المسلمين الحق في اداء الصلاه
للمسجد الاقصى يعني هناك تغيير هناك تغيير
ومحاولات تغير مستمره
للواقع في همم في المسجد الاقصى سيد مارتن
اندك ماذا ستفعل الولايات المتحده اذا ذلك
هي تطالب بعدم تغيير الوضع لكن الوضع
يتغير الان همم يعني هذا وزير لم يعد
لتمار بن غفير هو نفس الشخص الذي همم
اقتحم او حول الاقتحام سابقا الان هو وزير
رسمي في حكومه نتنياهو ووزير امن قومي
اسرائيلي كيف سيكون رد الفعل الامريكي
الحقيقي اذا ذلك باختصار ارجوك
اعتقد ان اداره بايدون
ما زالت تفكر بطريقه التعامل مع هذه
الحكومه الجديده في اسرائيل حول هذا
الموضوع وغيره وايضا التي نشاطات
الاستيطانيه في الضفه الغربيه وجهود ضمه
الغربيه التي هو جزء من برنامج هذه
الحكومه ايضا
مستشار القومي
يتحدث
ايضا سياتي الى واشنطن لقاء رئيس واحده
اذا اذا
الوقت مبكرا ولو طبعا لا شك ان المدار
الامريكيه موقف قوي شديد همم حول عدم
تغيير الوضع القائم فيما يتعلق
بحرم الشريف لكن كيف تعريف ذلك كما نشاهد
مناقشتنا هنا هذا غير واضح
نعم اتفقنا هناك الالتزام عدم اداء صلات
يهوديه في في الحرم الشريف هذا الجزء
القائم
زياره وزير اسرائيلي هذا شيء غير واضح
مربك وبالتالي الى هذا امر يحتاج الى نقاش
الاردن لها دور ايضا اذا ملك الاردن هو
الوصيه على
المسجد الاقصى الى ان يحصل النقاش
الامريكي الاسرائيلي وربما ايضا بمشاركه
الاردن الفصائل الفلسطينيه همم تحذر منه
شرب دينيه همم اسال السيد صالح النعامي عن
عن هذه الحرب الدينيه
خطوره فعلا نشوب حرب دينيه وانت اشرت الى
ان الهدف اساسا من هذه الزي وتكرار
الزيارات هو الوصول الى نبوءه حرب ياجوج
وماجوج كما يؤمن اليمين المتطرف في في
اسرائيل باختصار ارجوك
يعني اولا علينا
نسدد هنا انه لا يحق للمستوطنين الصهاينه
باقتحام المسجد الاقصى سواء للصلاه او
لغير الصلاه المسجد الاقصى هو المسجد
الاسلامي 100% وبالتالي ليس سواء تتفق ملك
الاردن ام لم يتفقوا الان فيما يتعلق
بالحرب الدينيه همم الذي يفرض هذه الحرب
هو الجانب الصهيوني
الفلسطينيون لا يقاتلون الصهاينه لانهم
يهود بل لانهم يمارسون الاحتلال نحن الان
لا نطلب وجود من كبير فقط لانه اقتحم
المسجد الاقصى لانه وجوده في في على هذه
الارض وجود غير شرعي هؤلاء احتلوا هذه
البلاد
وتطرده شعبها منها وبالتالي مساله الحرب
الدنيا الذي المسؤول عن فرض هذه الحرب هو
الجانب الصهيوني لكن بالنسبه للفلسطينيين
علينا ان نخرج من المساله التوصيفات وان
ننتقل من وصف حرب دينيه او غير دينيه الى
التوافق على برنامج وطني شامل لمواجهه هذا
التحدي كما قلت الحكومه سوني الحاليه
انتقلت يعني قطعت همم قطعت مع استراتيجيه
اداره الصراع الى استراتيجيه حسم الصراع
وبالتالي ان ان نستغرق في وصف السياسات
الصهيونيه حق دينيه وغير دينيه هذا لن
يفيد الان حان الوقت لتوافق على برنامج
وطني شامل والا انه والا فان الاسوء سيكون
همم سيكون هو القادم بكل تاكيد طيب سيد
مارتن انديكا لا يلاحظ ان اسرائيل هنا لا
تلقي بالالا ولا تعيره اهتماما لموقف اا
الاداره الامريكيه
هل بامكان الاداره الامريكيه ان تفعل شيئا
هل يمكن ان تردع اسرائيل همم وهي التي
حذرتها سابقا ولم تكترث همم اسرائيل لهذه
التحذيرات
اعتقد
على الارجح صحيح
ان بن كثير
المتطرفان في اللا يهتم معنا ولا يباليان
بما تقوده ولايه المتحده بل هم يستفزون
الولايات المتحده ويتحدونها
شعبيتهم ولكن نتنياهو رئيس وزراء يهتم
برايي الولايات المتحده في الولايات
المتحده مهمه جدا له
برنامجه برامج
القادمه من ايران وبرنامج النووي وايضا
بشكل متزايد لانه يريد ان يحقق السلام
والتطبيع مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والتي هي وضحت بان ما تريده السعوديه من
من اسرائيل هو التعاون مع الولايات
المتحده اذا اعتقد في هذا ان رئيس مؤيد
ستركز على نتنياهو وليس من زميلي
باختصار شديد هل يمكن التركيز على نتنياهو
من دون الحكومه وهل تبقى الحكومه اذا ركزت
اداره بيض على نتنياهو باختصار شديد همم
ارجوك
بكل بكل تاكيد لا يوجد حكومه بدون اثمار
بين كبير
وبدونش وبالتالي خط الذي يمليه اسمه اطرش
بالانجليزي هو الذي همم سيكون في النهايه
بمعنى
بمعنى ان ان الحكومه قد تكون في خطر بمعنى
بمعنى اولا
يعني يعني سيعبر الموقف الامريكي يعني هو
ابن يمينه يدرك بانه ال ال ال التمديد
الامريكي لن يفضي الى مثلا الى وقت
المساعدات الامريكيه او وقت الدعم
الامريكي الولايات المتحده التي قامت
الدنيا ولم تقعدها بسبب ما عدد الغزو
الروسي الاوكرانيا هي الان تحرك ساكنا لم
تحرك ساكنا منذ 67 حتى الان في ظل العدوان
الهائل الذي يتعرض لها الشعب الفلسطيني
وبالتالي هو يدرك انه حدود يعني هو
بامكانه يعني ان يغضب الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يتحمل همم
ردت فعلها ولكن ليس بامكانيه
ماذا لو اصرت حكومه نتنياهو على سلوكها
وموقفها على رغم همم يعني وسائل الضغط
التي ذكرتها اذا لم تنجح وسائل الضغط هذا
انا اتفق بانه من غير المحتمل ان الرئيس
قطعه مساعدات او قطعه مساعدات اسرائيل
المساعدات الامريكيه لاسرائيلي عن مساعدات
عسكريه وهو لا يريد ان يؤثر على امن
اسرائيل
من الولايات المتحده
وبالتالي هو يستطيع الطفل
حكومته تصرف بشكل تعارض مع المصالح
من الممكن في وضع شديد جدا يمكن تقول لا
يمكن تقول اسفين لقد حذرناكم لن نستطيع ان
نحميهم من الاجراءات الدوليه ضدكم من
الامم المتحده او من محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه او محكمه العدل الدوليه الذي سوف
يؤذونكم اذا يبدو له
من وسائل الضغط يمكن ولايه متحده ان
تستخدمها
حكومه اسرائيل على احترام هذه الخطوط
الحمراء شكرا
السابق لعمليه سلام في الشرق الاوسط من
نيويورك شكرا دكتور صالح نعم يا الخبير في
شؤون الاسرائيليه من غزه انتهت حلقتنا من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]